you have a three-year-old okay and
they're acting out they're pushing you
because they will because they want to
find out where the limits are
yeah so they'll push us because they
want to know where the limits are they
will push you back yes
so you let him push and push and you're
annoyed as hell but you won't admit it
because you're such a good guy and you
don't get
annoyed at your children and you always
love them no matter what they do and
all of that and so so you know your
child is annoyed the hell out of you and
so now you're annoyed and so then he
goes away and
maybe he goes and makes a picture and
maybe he's learned how to draw a person
that day or something that really
really indicates a step forward and he's
forgotten all about annoying you and he
comes trotting out with this picture
to show you and what he's hoping is that
you'll point to the picture and you'll
say
oh look you know yesterday you drew a
man but you didn't get his legs on right
and you didn't get his arms on right but
this time you got them right and you've
really made progress and so you
you're paying discriminating attention
and you're encouraging development
but no you don't do that because you're
annoyed you just say oh well i'm
go away i'm watching tv and so that's
how you get your bloody revenge
and if you don't think you'll do that
that's just because you don't know
anything about human beings
of course you'll do that and so you want
now
you know you think well you're an idiot
so maybe the kid's annoying you because
you're stupid that's highly probable so
maybe that's why it's useful to have a
wife around because she can help
point out where you're stupid and maybe
you won't be so stupid then
well right because you're gonna do this
on your own
no you're right and my my fiance always
says she's like you're gonna make me
discipline the kids i already know it i
i know you're gonna be a pushover dad
and i'm gonna be the one just
it's happening with the dog you know
she's got the electric
zap collar for the thing i can't even
touch that thing i just want to pet it i
want to give it little treats
totally undermine everything that she's
done and i feel like that's what i'm
gonna do with our kids as well yeah well
that you should
i would say you should pay attention to
that because you're probably right you
know
because the dog is a good practice dog's
a good practice
so you know so you you and if you're an
agreeable person you know if
and that's a temperamental trait
agreeableness and okay agreeable people
are compassionate
and polite essentially and they care
they don't like conflict they don't like
to hurt other people's feelings they're
not harsh they're not stubborn
it's highly probable given the way you
just described your interactions with
your dog that you're quite agreeable
but i would still say that you have an
ethical responsibility to establish the
standards that you want
to apply to your children and then
uphold them and you may have to do that
in intense dialogue with your fiance
because you don't want your household to
be set up so she's the bad guy
and has to carry all that weight yeah
and she resents me
of course and why wouldn't she no and
your children will get the wrong idea
too and besides they'll manipulate the
hell out of you because
you know they'll see you as the pushover
and then they won't have any respect for
their father and
you know and then they don't have any
respect for masculinity because you're
the representative of masculinity and
that's not good you want it to be as
close to 50 50 as you can manage
you